smoking damages two main parts of your
lungs your Airways also called bronchial
tubes and small air sacs called alveoli
with each breath air travels down your
windpipe called the trachea and enters
your lungs through your bronchial tubes
air then moves into thousands of tiny
alveoli where oxygen from the air moves
into your bloodstream and the waste
product carbon dioxide moves out of your
bloodstream
tiny hairlike projections called cilia
line your bronchial tubes and sweep
harmful substances out of your lungs
cigarette smoke irritates the lining of
your bronchial tubes causing them to
swell and make mucus
cigarette smoke also slows the movement
of your cilia causing some of the smoke
and bukas to stay in your lungs
while you are sleeping some of the cilia
recover and start pushing more
pollutants and mucus out of your lungs
when you wake up your body attempts to
expel this material by coughing
repeatedly a condition known as smokers
coughs over time chronic bronchitis
develops as your cilia stop working your
Airways become clogged with scars and
mucus and breathing becomes difficult
your lungs are now more vulnerable to
further disease
cigarette smoke also damages your LVL I
making it harder for oxygen and carbon
dioxide to exchange with your blood over
time so little oxygen can reach your
blood that you may develop emphysema a
condition in which you must gasp for
every breath and wear an oxygen tube
under your nose in order to breathe
chronic bronchitis and emphysema are
collectively called chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or COPD COPD is a
gradual loss of the ability to breathe
for which there is no cure